i love your backdrop maddie i'm feeling
that gotta have some fun when we're
playing with toys right
well and that is why i recruited my dear
friend
friend of the show it's leo kelly aka
the shirley temple king
hi hi drew how are you i am
great how are you i mean amazing
what's better than a platter of toys
there is nothing better than a platter
of toys all right maddie
what is first show us everything
yeah let's just jump right in so if you
need a hand i know something that'll
help this is the mega
cyborg hand and this is so cool
but what's even cooler is that kids will
build this working mechanical hand
with more than 200 pieces all while
they're learning about the science
of robotics and hydraulics so this is
really great for kids who are into
robots or kids who love building and
want to try something new yeah look at
that it has this really great
action with articulated fingers so you
can move each one
one by one so you can also grip and
lift objects i got it oh you oh
there you go i love the way this toy is
made
i can i can definitely agree this is a
great toy for kids that like
you know stem toys and things that you
get to build
because this is you get to build it
thumbs up
this is a thumbs up for me all right i'm
so into the first one okay what's next
maddie
yeah we're starting off strong all right
so have you ever wondered
what would happen if you mixed foosball
with basketball
well this is the foosball game and it is
an
epic mashup and now you can bring this
new sporting event right to your home
so first you release all of the mini
basketballs and then you move your
figure around to capture one
and then you use your hand to try to
score baskets
[Applause]
by the way you know who really liked
this game also my cats
i'm not kidding like all these little
orange balls were like flying around my
house and i was like what is going on
the cats went bananas over this game
okay leo what do you think of this game
yay nay
yay for me great okay good maddie what
do you got next
all right so in a world of endless
virtual calls and video chats
you're on mute has got to be the most
repetitive phrase of the year so now
this phrase is an
actual game so and you're on mute
players will take turns going behind
this screen
that will zoom in on your mouse
so there are three rounds in
strong connection you are going to talk
just like i am
right now in weak connection you
will just only use one word clues and
when you're on
mute you can only mouth the words i love
how much fun you guys are asking
all right so okay you're so cute in that
box thank you
i'm not going to say why don't we try it
around so i
sure i'm going to say a word okay that's
what i'm saying okay i'm not great at
reading lips in general
so got it okay you go yeah leo put your
screen up and then
yeah drew guess what he's saying beach
[Applause]
ball
thank you leo it's because we're a good
team by the way
i can't believe how quick on the draw
they were with this like they already
have a game called you're on mute it's
brilliant like they acted fast
it's crazy um leo uh why don't you come
around the front and maddie why don't
you explain
um what we have next yeah so i don't
know if kids or parents are going to be
more excited with this one
this is fomo and it is the toy of this
summer
it is a foam machine that will
have everything that you need to make
mountains of foam in just
minutes so you just add water plug it in
and you're ready to go and parents
everywhere are going to love
that the foam solution is hypoallergenic
and biodegradable so you're not going to
have a big mess in the backyard
i do know that leo is excited about this
and
i actually had to hide this from my
children
whoa whoa oh my gosh
this is so cool put that down and come
around here
all right you're right i know i'm like
an old grandma on them who cares
i know you're right leo i'm better than
that oh my gosh
okay ready this is the best toy out of
them all this is top five
leo's favorite toys probably gonna be
drew's top five two
i i just to know are we in agreement
that the number one toy out of all of
these is
fomo fomo agreed hands down hands
hands down this is obviously also my
hand
hands down drop the hand
i think the fomo's gonna be so embraced
just chill out with fomo for the rest of
the summer and guess what you don't have
to have
what fomo no fear of missing out here
okay and guess what thanks to toy
insider we're giving
each one of these toys all to our bffs
i really appreciate these wonderful
things in life
um i don't know if it's that it's the
little things or
we just want to see each other happy i
think this is just the ultimate example
of sparking joy
this is just a big bath all right thank
you maddie maholick and leo kelly my
dear
go to thedrewbraymoreshow.com for more
information on these toys